proverbs anthropomorphisms idiomatic
expressions
illusions metaphors repetitions
personifications xeomorphisms
anthropomorphisms and and on and on
a lot of literary features literary
devices
and these are markers of a very
sophisticated culture because of these
features the construction of
meaning from the test is very delicate
and complex
over time these fisher folk have
developed a kind of sub language
which i refer to as the fishes tongue
now the distinctive
distinctive features of the fishes tank
lie more in the manner in which the
waves are articulated
than in the laser cone itself the manner
in which they mention the words and the
structure of the phrases
is quite difficult to understand even
for so-called
native speakers of the dominant language
who are not the fish who are not part of
the fisher folk
so in general many of the west sound
muffled
consonants are attenuated or elited
words are deliberately used in contests
which are in congress with the regular
language
many of the borrowed words are
deliberately misappropriated or should i
say appropriated
so that even when one recognizes the
language
from which the word was borrowed the
words do not necessarily mean the same
thing
in the facial stunt furthermore several
wires are leading with
ambiguities and are often interspersed
with jargon
and a lot of non-logical vocalizations
now these deliberate use of ambiguities
have a purpose
and the purpose is uh among them
one of what tenna refers to refers to as
multivocality or multivocalic signifiers
the ability to creatively
have systems where you can have multiple
meanings at the same time
and that is a safety feature they were
recalls that
they repudiability principle it enables
them to speak about sensitive issues and
yet when they are taken on
they can repudiate and say they weren't
even talking about that
and for them this is very liberating
because their work
is along the shores which is an open
space where anybody can go it's a public
space
so the ability to create this fascist
tongue and the ability to use
all these features of the language help
them to communicate
among themselves and without the
understanding of who are not
meant to hear so it helps them to
channel the information
for for their listeners i would just
like to give one example from the
translations
and basically what what the lead singer
is saying is that
i am just a simple man singing a simple
song
because i get wet from the sea my sweat
is hardly noticed
i am not the one who made promises for
votes
but when the frog feels the heat from
the pepe
that the lizard has eaten it is worth
talking about
i don't know what i'm even talking about
i'm just singing a simple song
in the second verse of this the singer
goes on to say
i am just a simple man singing a simple
song
because i am not all dressed up in suit
and tie
i am hardly noticed i am not the one who
traced
sex for favors but when the food is put
on the chair
and the table is used as the seat it is
worth talking about
i don't know what i am saying i'm just
singing a simple song
now in the last line of each of the
verses that i read
the singer says that claims that he
doesn't know what he's saying
but the content of the song is popular
knowledge it
is it is news mainstream news some of it
are political issues
about government appointees who are
appointed on the basis of sex or who
the general public think that they are
not qualified but because of certain
reasons they are appointed
and so songs like this help them to give
and run commentaries about
rather sensitive issues and then because
of these features that i already
mentioned if you take them on
they will say they were not even talking
about that this is the element of
reputability
that i'm talking about